this covert 19 pandemic will continue to
have an influence on our lives in
several ways in 2022
it has a significant impact on the job
market across the world having said that
it also has led to substantial
technological transformations in the it
field with time new technologies are
evolving technologies that help address
global challenges and make life simpler
in the coming years on that note hey
guys welcome to yet another interesting
video by simply learn today we will be
discussing the top technologies of 2022
so here's a list of new technologies of
2022 that you should watch out for
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update at number 5 we have iot the
internet of things is fast becoming an
integral part of our lives iot is a
futuristic technology recognized for its
social and technological marvels iot
devices are increasing by almost 31
percent every year and according to
reports there will be 30 billion iot
devices by 2022.
iot has aided firms in improving
customer service streamlining operations
and increasing profits companies are
becoming more involved in iot few such
companies are my tree ibm ge digital and
verizon to name a few the top in-demand
iot skills are machine learning and ai
python and javascript big data and
node.js
according to reports in 2017 market
revenue for iot surpassed 100 billion
dollars and it is estimated that this
amount could rise to about 1.6 trillion
by 2025. number four we have cyber
security several organizations have
fallen prey to cyber attacks including
big names like facebook linkedin and
yahoo the onset of the kovit 19 pandemic
has served as a trigger for a rise in
the number of cyber attacks across the
globe hence the field of cyber security
holds paramount importance in today's
times
few of the best cyber security companies
are cisco microsoft mcafee and ibm to
name a few to work in the field of cyber
security skills like knowledge of
operating systems networking
virtualization and programming are
beneficial
according to reports post kovit 19 the
global cyber security market size is
estimated to grow from
217.19 billion us dollars in 2021 to
345.4 billion us dollars by 2026. and
number three we have blockchain
blockchain is one of the contemporary
technologies with a bright future
currently blockchain is revolutionizing
almost every sector
banking health care and politics are a
few industries that may profit from
establishing a decentralized digital
ledger that monitors and saves data in
several locations making forgeries
difficult companies that uses blockchain
are hsbc
barclays walmart and pfizer to name a
few
blockchain developers need to know
concepts like cryptography data
structures and computer networking
reports state that by 2022 worldwide
expenditures on blockchain
infrastructures are expected to reach
11.7 billion us dollars number two we
have cloud services there's a lot more
to the cloud than just a robust storage
solution the year 2021 proved to be a
watershed moment for cloud computing
just like the year before it allowed
more flexibility for companies to
operate in the face of kobit 19.
according to it experts cloud computing
will be at the forefront of all
technologies to address significant
business issues in the next few years
few companies that have moved to the
cloud are pinterest instagram netflix
and target for a successful career in
cloud computing you need to have
knowledge of databases programming linux
networking and apis
according to research by 2022 revenue
from the public cloud sector is
anticipated to increase to
331 billion us dollars finally at the
top of the list of top 10 technologies
we have artificial intelligence or ai
ai is revolutionizing business sectors
and making our lives easier by
automating complex tasks and makes
future predictions
ai is playing a great role in medicine
manufacturing education and mobility
from self-driving cars to smart devices
ai is everywhere ai also finds its
application in building robots and chat
bots some of the top companies working
on ai are google microsoft tesla ibm and
facebook some of the skills you need to
possess to become an expert in
artificial intelligence are python
programming mathematics machine learning
and deep learning as per markets and
market the global artificial
intelligence market will grow from
58.3 billion us dollars in 2021 to
309.6 billion us dollars by 2026 at a
cagr of 39.7
with so much advancement in the field of
artificial intelligence and companies
spending billions of dollars there's
absolutely no doubt that ai is the
future
but the question arises whether ai's the
greatest technology that humanity has
ever seen well only the future will tell
us with that being said if you are
interested in learning to create
something interesting and help make a
difference check out simplylearn's
postgraduate program in ai and machine
learning in partnership with purdue
university and collaboration with ibm it
covers topics like machine learning deep
learning statistics and nlp amongst
others with such significant
technological breakthroughs the future
appears to be brighter than ever there's
simply no stopping it have you heard
about innovations that have been
recently implemented let us know in the
comments section below thank you for
being here and watch out for more such
informative videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here